[Musique]
le gouvernement est un communiqué quand
ça l'arrangé la plupart du temps quand
même il est dans le fameux en même temps
si cher à la majorité aujourd'hui j'ai
souhaité défendre une augmentation de
skins aux acteurs de la montagne pour
les exploitants de remontées mécaniques
ou les mères france stations de montagne
pour justement il rassuré je crois que
le gouvernement aujourd'hui elle est
l'opportunité pour voir tout simplement
y répondre est simple la réponse n'était
pas au rendez-vous et des pagnes pas de
plus dans la classe c est le
gouvernement a créé que édicter une une
liste à la prévert de toutes les mesures
que l'on peut mettre en place pour
essayer de sauver les stations de ski
mais à aucun moment on a essayé
d'apporter une réponse claire
qu'attendez les stations de montagne je
m'étais proposait justement d'être leur
porte parole aux produits pour essayer
de rassurer et rassurer aussi les
visiteurs les stations montagne vécu
depuis deux saisons maintenant une
période très difficile elle avait besoin
d'être encouragé voilà les la saison de
ski vient de démarrer et stations de
montagne aujourd'hui n'ont aucune
certitude ils n'ont aucune réponse quant
à la position du planétaire sera-t-il
appliqué ou non qui aurons les remontées
mécaniques à l'heure d'aujourd'hui 20 90
a pas réussi à répondre
[Musique]